Griese everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where today I am doing pot to
of my weird words videos I missed
rallying has been living in the States
since 2015 and I've been writing down
every single word it has a totally
different meaning in the u.s. to what it
does in Australia of course I should
mention all these things were
region-based so it might not apply to
either of the entire country so let's
start off this one I ultimately admit is
really dumb on Australia's pot the
videos that accompanies of song in
Australia we call a film clips in
America they call that a music video
because it doesn't really make sense
that we would call a music video some
clip that's all bad if you take time off
of work in a trailer we call that
holiday in the US they call that
vacation I think a holiday specifically
in the u.s. is used to describe when you
are going on like international travel
whereas holiday in Australia can mean
you're just taking a week off it's a lot
more broad this is a good one does the
phrase stepped it mean anything to you
staffed it and Australia is kind of
slang it basically means like spell over
yourself so someone on a bike falls off
their bike you would say they stacked it
here's one where Australia's definitely
wins the thing on the side of the car
that lets people know if you are turning
in a certain direction we call that an
indicator in the US they call that a
blinker obviously it's an indicator
because it indicates which way you're
turning lots of things blank the kind of
warm thing that you wear in winter is
called a jumper and I feel like jumper
is a pretty broad term that also
includes like a hoodie or like a zip up
hoodie which I guess you call a jacket
in the US and also a pullover a jumper
is basically any of those things this
one's a fun one the word route in the US
you can recruit team meaning you are
supporting a sports team you are rooting
for them means you are cheering for them
or backing them rooting in Australia
means having sex I think enough people
in Australia know that route in the u.s.
kind of means cheering on so if you say
it in conversation with Australian
they'll know what you mean but yeah
remember that it has a double meaning
and that double meaning is sex
the thing that is on the back of a bed
usually the thing that is pressed
the wall in the US is called a headboard
in Australia I call that a bed head and
then in the US bed head is related to
half but for Australians that would just
be bed hair if you order something from
a store and you want to take it with you
rather than eating it in stall and
Australia that's called getting
something takeaway in the US that's
called getting it to go this next one's
kind of hard to explain
I guess candy in the u.s. is don't fully
understand it lollies in Australia
things that are sugary not necessarily
hard
gummy bears are counted as lollies
basically like any sugary sweets is a
lolly in the US and pretty sure if it's
hard it's candy we also know six weeks
very often so I think like sweets and
candy a kind of just more American used
enough but one of my housemates feel
that I was sick and asked me to buy her
a gummy candy and I was super confused a
bag that you like clip around your waist
that has a little compartment at the
front in Australia is called a bum bag
in the u.s. it is called a fanny pack
they're both equally bizarrely crass
like I don't know why it's a bum bag or
why it's a fanny pack
but yeah because Australia obviously
shares a lot in common with the UK Fanny
can also translate to me vagina but
that's really only referenced in
kindergarten the dot at the end of a
sentence in Australia we call a
full-stop in the US they call it a
period I mean I know that it is also
called a period and doubles as a period
but I said something of the day that was
like I don't always use full stops when
I'm texting and some of my American
friends were like what does that mean
this is another slang one in Australia
if I'm super busy I can say I'm flat out
if I am flat out at work will flood out
today flat out this weekend that
basically just means I'm non-stop busy
doing this with your fingers in
Australia we call that clicking your
fingers in the US they call that
snapping your fingers but I kind of feel
like doing it in like a really sassy way
like would be kind of snapping the thing
at a store where you give the person
money for the stuff that you buy and
it's really we call a tilt in the u.s.
they call a register cash
and last but not least when you complete
a video game you finish the main
storyline another kind of slang term in
Australia we will say clock it I caught
this video game in the USA just a
finished and that's all the words that I
have written down and so far
obviously I have two videos of this I
will keep working on this list as I find
new weird things that are different that
I didn't even know about and yeah
there's some stuff that I feel like so
many people know that I don't even
bother I mentioned in these videos like
flip flops and songs I also have to
thank the people who donated off in my
last video I even have a man will Stefan
have a man or Habermann I remember you
reaching out to me on Twitter thank you
so much Steven Matt Hiro 8212 autoroute
zero and Keaton Piet's who both likes
ducks and said that he is a dolphin good
job again thank you guys so much for
donating for those who don't know to
support my channel feature it's kind of
like a tip job you favorite YouTube
created the link is on my about page
only available in some countries and
that is it for me today guys I will see
you guys next time okay